oh man you want to hear something really
sad
yeah is that i mean i know you don't
want to hear something sad i they're
starting shooting today
um on um and you just couldn't be there
i couldn't be there because i jump into
my
edit tomorrow i thought you're going to
say because of the podcast you really
you really ruined the whole
thing man rosie you really blew it i'm
doing your podcast tom bank but you're
working on the movie so you have a
certain like when you're done with a
movie you have like a couple of weeks of
editing and uh sound is like a month
like right so you couldn't do it and
they wanted you to do it of course and i
wanted to do it they were so spectacular
and um here's the connection there so um
the dp my dp uh frank pereira also is
shooting reno so frank went you know to
idaho and did outpost with me on this
mountain this crazy shoot rested for a
week we just got back a week ago and now
he's jumping in to do arena they do that
talk about a hero talk about him the
strength to do that well he's incredible
he's just truly um
he's just great and he's gonna crush it
on reno too and he he had shot um the
last season of reno as well when the one
that i um was on the season eight i
think or maybe season seven whatever the
last one was
but they're doing a movie now and i miss
those guys so much and uh the whole gang
i mean we had such a blast when we did
the show on the now defunct quibby um
but now but but those i think those
episodes are now being redone to
premiere on uh somewhere else do you
want to jump on another series would you
rather continue doing movies would you
what is it do you want to do it all
right here's what i'd like to do rosie
i'd love to
do a show for a few months a year and
make a little bit of money
and then just finance my movies because
you know what was really nice
is uh being able to hire who you want
and
um being in charge being in a way uh in
in charge yeah
you like being in control because in a
lot of ways your whole life not to say
you haven't had control but you're the
studio is is is you know yeah
hanging over yeah they're the most
people yeah they're the money people oh
you want me to do this movie you're the
boss i'm just the guy who's coming on
the show yeah oh it's always like that
but this and that's okay i mean that's
yeah i like doing that too sometimes but
like for
at least for this first movie i'm like
if it's going to be my first maybe only
one who knows how it's going to turn out
i gotta fail my own way like if it's
going to not work i got to make sure
it's because of me and not because
someone else was